si empezamos con un aldehído acetona y
agregamos un ácido o base encontraremos
que el aldehído acetona está en
equilibrio con este producto de la
derecha que se conoce como en ol en por
el doble enlace y hoy porque tenemos un
alcohol justo aquí esta es la forma en
all y esta es la forma set
estas dos moléculas son isómeros así que
les llamaremos tanto meros analicemos
nuestra acetona para ver cómo podemos
formar nuestro en all si observamos el
carbono que se encuentra junto al
carbono en el carbón y lo a este carbono
le llamaremos carbono alfa y tenemos dos
hidrógenos unidos
a este carbono alfa se llaman protones
alfa entonces podemos pensar en
transferir uno de estos protones alfa
del carbono al oxígeno puede que no sea
el mismo protón pero vamos a verlo así
también podemos pensar en mover este
doble enlace que se encuentra entre el
carbono y el oxígeno y moverlo hacia acá
entre estos dos carbonos entonces al
transferir un protón alfa y cambiar el
doble enlace podemos pasar de la forma
acepto a la forma en all y este
hidrógeno que tenemos del lado izquierdo
también lo tenemos del lado derecho que
sería este hidrógeno ahora echemos un
vistazo a un mecanismo por catálisis
ácida si empezamos con nuestro aldehído
o se torna y agregamos
tres o más lo primero que ocurre es la
proto nación de nuestro carbón y lo
entonces un par de electrones toma un
protón dibujemos lo que nos queda 'hemos
protón ado el carbón hilo y ahora este
oxígeno tiene una carga formal positiva
supongamos que empezamos con una de ido
así que tenemos un hidrógeno entonces
este par de electrones en el oxígeno
tomó un protón ahora como podemos
dibujar una estructura de resonancia
para esto si movemos estos electrones
hacia el oxígeno tenemos un grupo r y
ahora tenemos nuestro oxígeno con dos
pares de electrones libres pero como le
quitamos un enlace
este carbono aquí tenemos una carga
formal positiva así que estos electrones
se movieron hacia nuestro oxígeno
este es nuestro intermediario muy bien
encontremos a nuestro carbono alfa aquí
está aquí tenemos dos protones alfa
entonces una molécula de agua entra la
dibujaré por aquí y funcionará como base
tomará este protón dejando estos
electrones que se moverán para formar un
doble enlace dibujemos el producto
tenemos un grupo r
y ahora hemos formado un doble enlace
entre estos dos carbonos después tenemos
un oxígeno
un hidrógeno por aquí y otro por acá
sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones en azul se movieron para
formar este doble enlace después estos
electrones en rojo se movieron hacia el
oxígeno y estos son los electrones en
rosa
este es nuestro enorme y empezamos con
la forma acepto por eso se le llama auto
maría cetto enol ahora echemos un
vistazo a la versión por catálisis
básica una vez más empezaremos con
nuestro aldehído acetona pero esta vez
agregaremos una base como por ejemplo
hidróxido entonces encontremos nuestro
carbono alfa aquí está y tenemos dos
protones alfa
que la base toma este protón dejando
estos electrones en el carbono dibujemos
el avión que nos queda aquí tenemos el
carbón hilo y supongamos que empezamos
con un aldehído y tenemos un par de
electrones libres en este carbón estos
electrones en rosa se movieron a este
carbono es un carbón muy bien esta es
una forma en la que podemos mostrar el
avión y podemos dibujar una estructura
de resonancia si estos electrones en
rosa se mueven hacia acá empujarán a
estos electrones hacia el oxígeno
dibujemos la estructura de resonancia
aquí tenemos un doble enlace
ahora nuestro oxígeno tiene tres pares
de electrones libres lo que le da una
carga formal negativa así que los
electrones en rosa se movieron para
formar este enlace pi y estos electrones
se movieron al oxígeno entonces tenemos
dos formas en las que podemos encontrar
este año y a este año se le conoce como
unión en olate observen que el año no la
pto tiene dos estructuras de resonancia
una en donde la carga negativa se
encuentra en el carbono esta es la forma
del carbayón
carbunión y tenemos otra en donde la
carga negativa se encuentra en el
oxígeno a esta le llamaremos oxidación
como el oxígeno es más electro negativo
que el carbono es más fácil que soporte
la carga negativa así que el oxi a nyon
contribuye más en el híbrido de
resonancia muy bien ahora pensemos en el
último paso del mecanismo para formar
nuestro enol si tomamos el oxi a nyon lo
único que tenemos que hacer es protón ar
este oxígeno así que dibujemos una
molécula de agua donará un protón
digamos que estos electrones en azul
toman este protón dejando estos
electrones dibujemos nuestro producto
final tenemos un grupo r
el doble enlace y este oxígeno que hemos
protón ado para formar nuestro en all
como producto resaltemos estos
electrones en azul así es como podemos
llegar al producto usando una catálisis
básica pero hablaremos más sobre esto en
otros vídeos ahora veamos una situación
en la que el carbono alfa es un centro
girar
este es nuestro carbono alfa y es un
centro girar supongamos que el aire y la
rb prima son diferentes así que tenemos
cuatro cosas diferentes unidas a este
carbono aquí el carbono alfa tiene una
hibridación sp3 con geometría te trae
drica y no importa si es el enantiómero
r o ese pero podemos ver que sólo
tenemos un protón alfa y como sólo
tenemos 1
podemos formar nuestro enorme ya sea por
catálisis ácida o básica podemos
transferir este protón al oxígeno y
mover el doble enlace así formamos
nuestro enorme ahora veamos que le pasó
al carbono alfa del lado izquierdo tiene
una hibridación sp3 con geometría te
trae drica y ahora tiene una hibridación
sp2 con geometría trigo no al plan es
decir que no importa cuál era la estéreo
química del lado izquierdo porque una
vez que formamos nuestro enol no hay
finalidad si queremos regresar a la
forma aceptó tenemos dos posibilidades
una es formar el enantiómero con el que
empezamos pero la otra es formar el otro
enantiómero en donde el hidrógeno que
antes estaba hacia nosotros
ahora queda lejos de nosotros y el grupo
rebi prima queda hacia nosotros entonces
al formar el en all podemos obtener una
mezcla de enantiómero y si esperamos lo
suficiente podemos obtener la misma
cantidad de este y de este y estarán en
equilibrio con la forma en ahora veamos
rápidamente dos ejemplos de la forma
acepto y enorme aquí del lado izquierdo
tenemos ciclohexano y del lado derecho
tenemos la versión en all de eso este es
nuestro carbono alfa y podemos mover
estos electrones hacia acá empujando a
estos electrones así obtenemos la forma
en all pero resulta que la forma acepto
es la forma favorecida el equilibrio en
realidad tiende hacia la izquierda
incluso en condiciones normales es decir
sin catálisis ácida o básica sólo hay
una pequeña cantidad de enol aunque
existen algunos casos en donde el en all
es extra estabilizado como en este
ejemplo que tenemos abajo esta es la
forma aceptó y la forma en all
nuevamente podemos pensar en estos
electrones que se mueven hacia acá
empujando a estos electrones para darnos
la forma en all esta forma en all es
especialmente estabilizada y se conoce
como fenol
este es el fenol y gracias a la
presencia de este anillo aromático es
que el fenol tiene estabilidad extra
esta vez el equilibrio tiende hacia la
derecha es decir que favorece la forma
en all así que en este caso tenemos una
estabilidad especial